so I got out a textbook it was called
race class and gender and it's it's an
anthology that's used in cultural
studies courses in Women's Studies
courses and it's sort of the go-to text
so I'm told and I'm reading it and I
turned it and I I would turn to page 14
and I can tell you it's page 14 because
I was so astounded by what I found and
it said we that oh it says objectivity
as found through rational thought is a
Western and masculine concept that we
will challenge throughout this text yeah
right yeah yeah and I said it's too bad
it's too bad that you're shocked by that
because the PC types have been saying
exactly doubts since the 1970s like that
is exactly make no mistake about this
this is why McClatchy is wrong this
isn't this isn't something they're
secret again this is the dead statement
oh yeah this is that the whole notion of
logic and coherence and empirical data
for that matter it's a very nature let's
question let's question the definition
of evidence because the underlying idea
remember the underlying idea here is
that all hierarchies are predicated on
power so if the reason that I put
forward something as evidence isn't
because it's evidence it's because it's
evidence that I get to have that
position of power and so if you're a
postmodernist and you say well I'm going
to question your evidence what you think
you're saying is you're going to
question my claim to that arbitrary
power the whole idea that there's
evidence outside of claims of arbitrary
power the post modernists dispensed
without in the 1970s that's Derrida
that's exactly what he said is all this
time I've been trying to get samples of
thousands so that I could say you know
this is a little bit we can say
something not just in generalized no no
that just demonstrates how thoroughly
entrenched you are in the reigning
patriarchal ideologies I guess and I was
just hoping to get beyond anecdotal
there's no beyond acne dude there's no
beyond anecdotal that's become a
methodology that's Otto experience it's
called Auto ethnography there's a
technical term for it and Auto
ethnography is the publication of a
journal of a private diary essentially
in a
hypothetically reputable repute abou
academic journal just it's only because
of in the last three or four years that
these things have been happening I said
well where do they get this how do they
how do they find these thoughts yes well
we do we don't we don't want to fall
into the mistake of making of making the
assumption that this hasn't been thought
through people are not just
misunderstanding what evidence is that
isn't what's happening at all when they
say they want to question the definition
of evidence that's exactly what they
mean when they say we want to question
the definition of evidence because the
definition of evidence currently
supports the scientific power structure
in chemistry say and that's
fundamentally dominated by let's say
white men we can go after the definition
of evidence itself and that's how we're
going to bring it down and so the next
people on the hit list are going to be
the biologists they're already under
attack the people that said that
mathematics is whiteness yeah yeah yeah
definitely I didn't know that
mathematics could have a race hmm yeah
but it's thinking the thing is there's
nothing illogical about these claims
once you accept this central axioms the
axioms are straightforward the world is
a battleground of power hierarchies
that's what it is there isn't anything
else outside of that and each power
hierarchy generates its own internal
narrative including rules for what
constitutes evidence that support and
buttress the structure of that hierarchy
and because the hierarchies exclude then
it's in the best interests of the people
who are excluded to invert the hierarchy
and of course they also regard that as
just even though that's part of the
incoherence of the entire argument
that's where they have to turn to to
Marxism but make no mistake about it
this isn't this isn't accidental it
isn't people misunderstanding what
constitutes evidence not at all